this is a production of Cornell
University
hi I'm Rebecca Benner on the science and
strategy director for the Nature
Conservancy of New York and it's really
exciting to be here today and I took my
time thinking all the right people I
would run out of my five minutes so
consider yourself Thanks The Nature
Conservancy is a global conservation
nonprofit we work in all 50 states
across the country in 72 countries
across the world and our global program
as Dave mentioned has been working in
agriculture for a really long time in a
number of different ways but now we're
really thinking a lot more about soil
and I actually stole that tagline
rethink soil from our global team and
the Nature Conservancy in general is
thinking a lot about this nexus between
food water and climate change I'll say
that the Nature Conservancy in New York
we're actually somewhat new to thinking
about this and to working with all of
you in this space and we're really
excited to be here today to learn from
you and to understand how we can
contribute to this ongoing dialogue so
I'm going to tell you a little bit about
the stuff that we do in New York and how
it relates to soils I'm hoping that as
we continue this dialogue we learn how
we can add value to these conversations
so I'm gonna tell you a little bit about
water you might say why is she talking
about water when this is about soils
partly that's because dave told me too
but the other reason is because we've
been working around water for a really
long time and we think there's a
beautiful nexus with soil health and
water health so I'm going to show you a
little bit some of the science that
we've brought to the table around water
quality and I can say that these maps
though they're very pretty if you look
at the story behind them it's a little
bit disturbing so this is a map that is
done based on the sparrow model from
USGS by one of our scientists at the
Nature Conservancy but it's really
trying to do is it's a modeling exercise
so I'll just put that out there it's
trying to understand that if we had a
proposed standard around water Claudie
New York which the state did propose a
while ago where would we be in terms of
meeting that standard darker the purple
the further away from that standard so
in this case we're looking at nitrogen
barkas purple would be greater than five
times above the standards in terms of
the nitrogen concentrations that we
would want in our waterways to have
healthy waters the only places that
actually would excuse me meet the
standard would be the Adirondacks and
the Catskills you
see those areas a colorful map in the
lower left that's trying to tell you
what those sources of nitrogen are that
beautiful blue is actually atmospheric
deposition so we have a huge amount of
atmospheric deposition of nitrogen in
New York the orange is agriculture
the yellow is nurse and more relevant to
the conversations we're having today
similar story around phosphorus again
the darker greens are probably a or more
about in terms of the concentrations
above this proposed standard and again
in the lower left you see the powerful
map that tells you sort of where those
contributions are coming from again here
you can see the yellow really driving
most of that picture other than the
green the yellow is really is manure and
then again the orange is agriculture and
so this tells a story about our waters
it tells us a little bit about what's
happening with nutrients in our waters
at the Nature Conservancy we feel this
is all of our issue and the community's
issues to solve we all benefit from
having cleaner water we need clean water
to have production of food New York is
one of the most important food producers
we need to be able to continue to play
in that sphere with climate change and
somebody already mentioned this New
York's importance in the agricultural
sphere will only increase so together we
need to start thinking about our waters
and make sure that they're healthy and
this is where I come to soils so the
Nature Conservancy as I said is really
thinking about this nexus between soil
water and climate change in New York we
have been working a lot on climate
mitigation particularly trying to work
with the state to achieve our very
ambitious renewable energy targets but
now we're actually turning 4 it's
thinking about how does nature play a
role in sequestering carbon so of course
as a Nature Conservancy we've been
thinking a lot about forests and I
suspect you'll hear more of this from
our colleagues at Cornell a little bit
later today we're actually starting to
think a little bit about how does
changing agricultural practices actually
helps to sequester and store carbon
similar to many of the things they've
talked about earlier so the Nature
Conservancy's soil health program really
focuses on cover crops crop rotation and
reduced tillage we are part of many
national partnerships including the soil
health partnership which is a
partnership created by the natural Corn
Growers Association and they are
collecting data off of farms all across
the country to try to
understand the benefits of soil health
practices we also think a lot about how
does that relate to nutrient management
we are incredibly excited to be a
partner in the for our program there's a
4-hour nutrient stewardship table right
over there you can learn more about it
working with my Sabba and the fertilizer
institute thinking about how do we work
with nutrient applications to actually
do better nutrient management on our
farms and how does this then link to
carbon storage and the ability of nature
to help us fight against global climate
change so that's really the Nexus that
we hope to actually add value and bring
to the table we have a lot of expertise
on science a lot on water a lot on
climate mitigation we're really excited
to be part of this dialogue and we hope
and we are learning from all of you
about how food water climate all comes
together in our soils this has been a
production of Cornell University on the
web at cornell edu